and welcome to the Commission's press
room today 19th of September it's our
pleasure to have with us Commissioner
Mark oficio to discuss the state aid
decision taking just now so the
commissioner and I'll give a statement
before we then move on to our customary
Q&A session commissioner well thank you
the Commission has today decided that
the non taxation of certain McDonald's
profit in Luxembourg is not illegal
state aid our case concerned two tax
rulings granted by Luxembourg to
McDonald's in 2009 these accepts from
taxation in Luxembourg all franchise
profits that McDonald's receives from
third parties operating McDonald's
outlets in Europe Ukraine and Russia in
the first ruling Luxembourg falsely
assumed that these prophets were taxable
in the u.s. they were not in the second
ruling Luxembourg then removed any
obligation on McDonald's to prove that
the revenues were taxable in the US this
means that these profits were neither
tax in Luxembourg nor in the US the
Commission investigated under EU stated
rules whether this double non taxation
was a result of Luxembourg miss applying
its national laws and the Luxembourg us
double taxation treaty in favor of
McDonald's EU in you stated rules
prevents Member States from giving
unfair advantages to only selected
companies including illegal tax benefits
however our in-depth investigation has
shown that the reason for the double non
taxation in this case is a mismatch
between Luxembourg and US tax laws and
not a special treatment by Luxembourg
there
for we concluded that Luxembourg did not
break EU state age rules let me give you
a few more details our case concerns
McDonald's Europe franchising a
luxembourg-based subsidiary of the
McDonald's Corporation this company also
has a branch in the u.s. McDonald's
Europe franchising owns the rights to
the McDonald's brands and other related
rights it licenses these rights to third
parties who operates the McDonald's fat
fast food outlets and pay franchise fees
to McDonald's Europe franchising in
February 2009 McDonald's Europe
franchising contacted the Luxembourg tax
authorities they contact them to ask for
a tax ruling confirming that profits
from its franchise rights would not be
taxable in Luxembourg McDonald's claimed
that this was because these rights were
attrition attributed to its us French it
further argued that Luxembourg us double
taxation treaty accepts from taxation in
Luxembourg any income that may be taxed
in the u.s. if of course the company has
the taxable presence there for example
through a branch in March 2009 the
Luxembourg authorities issued a first
tax ruling agreeing with McDonald's
interpretation of the double taxation
treaty at the same time they requested
that the company provide proof that the
income of the u.s. branch had been
declared and could indeed be taxed in
the US however six months later the
Luxembourg tax authorities issued a
second tax ruling that removed this
requirement to provide proof
in other words Luxembourg confirmed that
the income is except from taxation in
luck
work as well even though it's not
taxable in the u.s. branch you may
wonder how Luxembourg can rely on a
treaty meant to avoid double taxation to
endorse double non taxation we ask
ourselves the same question and this is
why we open the state aid investigation
in December 2015 the purpose of opening
such an investigation is to give Member
States and the company concerns as well
as other third parties the opportunity
to submit their views to the
Commission's preliminary concerns and
then we carefully assess them in the
short summary of our conclusions in the
case is that the double taxation treaty
between Luxembourg and the US explains
Luxembourg's tax treatment of McDonald's
Luxembourg and that they did not miss
apply the treaty in a selective manner
and on that basis they didn't break EU
state aid rules the more complicated if
this wasn't complicated enough for you
the more complicated answer starts with
a taxation concept called permanent
establishment a company has a permanent
establishment in a specific country if
this means that it carries out business
and has a taxable presence there the
Luxembourg US double taxation treaty
says that blocksberg
cannot tax the profit of companies if it
may be taxed in the US because they have
a permanent establishment there
Luxembourg can assume that the income of
this permanent establishment is being
taxed in the US however whether a
permanent establishment exists in the
u.s. is assessed differently by the US
and by the Luxembourg tax authorities
under their respective tax codes the
u.s. did
consider the u.s. branch of McDonald's
Europe franchising to be a permanent
establishment under its tax laws and so
it did not tax the profits of this US
branch
however the Luxembourg authorities
considered that the same US branch
fulfilled all the conditions necessary
to be a permanent establishment under
looks Luxembourg tax law it was
therefore exempted it therefore exempt
of this income from Luxembourg taxation
in line with a double taxation treaty
the result was double non taxation of
the income by Luxembourg and the u.s.
however it was not due to any special
treatments awarded by Luxembourg to
McDonald's which was the issue under
investigation under our state eight
rules in other words Luxembourg's tax
treatment of McDonald's is not illegal
under EU state rules as usual we will
publish the non-confidential version of
our decision as soon as we have agreed
with Luxembourg on any business secrets
that needs to be removed from it of
course the fact remains that McDonald's
did not pay any taxes in Luxembourg on
these profits and this is not how it
should be from a tax fairness point of
view and this is why I very much welcome
that the Luxembourg government is taking
legislative steps to address the issue
that arose in this case and avoid such
situations in the future among other
things Luxembourg will strengthen the
criteria under its tax code to define a
permanent establishment this proposal is
currently with the Luxembourg Parliament
once adopted the new provision will
require the taxpayer in certain
circumstance to provide a certificate of
residence in the other country
if it wants to benefit from the tax
exception in Luxembourg this would be
proof that the other country recognizes
the existence of a taxable permanent
establishment of that country this new
provision is presented to the Luxembourg
Parliament together with other measures
to transpose the e use our common and he
tax avoidance directive over the past
few years we have seen an international
determination to deal with the issue of
tax avoidance through closing loopholes
in tax laws and working with the OECD's
base erosion and profit shifting project
also within our own European community
under the responsibility of my
colleagues bodies Dombrowski and PMO's
go Vichy the Commission has pursued a
coherent strategy towards fair taxation
and greater transparency and member
states have been using this momentum to
reform their corporate taxation
framework to make it both fairer and
more efficient
finally just a short updates on the
progress made to implement the
Commission's decision requiring Member
States to recover unpaid taxes and this
is important because if not recovered
well then the companies continue to
benefit from illegal advantages in May
Luxembourg completed the recovery of
more than two hundred and eighty million
euros from Amazon of which 21 million
euros is interest I'm also happy to
confirm that Ireland has now recovered
the full illegal aid from Apple the
final amount recovered is fourteen point
three billion euros which 1.2 billion
euros is interest this money will be
held in an escrow account pending the
outcome of the ongoing appeal of the
Commission's decision before the EU
courts this means that we can proceed to
closing the infringement process
against Ireland for failure to implement
the decision these are important steps
to tackling more to Nationals tax
avoidance and to meeting our ultimate
goal of ensuring that not all most
companies but all companies big or small
pay their fair share of taxes in the
future thank you many